can I ask one question since we have a
genuine many worlders sitting with us
[Laughter]
well yesterday I was talking to people
who were who were bothered about just
getting one universe into existence yes
and they were having a lot of difficulty
and now you're telling us you the many
world errs that every instant this
universe is branching off lots of other
ones yes right there are lots of other
things that are happening in the
universe which seem very wild but this
is lots of lots of universes well there
are lots of particles in galaxies that
are doing lots of weird weird things and
and those are small numbers compared to
the number of many words because when
does it branch off is it when I have a
thought you have a thought of Hedgehog
has a thought well that there are yes
another branching where are they I think
the story while this is it's what
matters to a physicist is whether it
works for predicting stuff in a way that
produces the least amount of
contradictions and as far as so you know
it's it's a it's very expensive on
universities as Paul Davis put it once
but it it really works and it removes
lots of these contradictions to come up
with other interpretations so why not
it's also worth bearing in mind that the
the circle branching in two distinct
worlds or universes isn't really an act
of creation yes it's just enough toys
for intiation so the fundamental
ontology doesn't have worlds in it at
all you've just got the quantum wave
function field II thing and then worlds
are just particular kinds of structures
within the quantum wave function
anything so they're not actual world
okay I'm not sure I believe you at all
oh go ahead much more natural instead of
saying that the universe branch is often
too many other universes and so on to
say no nature only has one solution but
our models of it are imperfect so our
understanding of the universe branches
offer to many different
my name on the predicted future that
many possible predictions which might be
- like the weather forecast so much
percent chance of rain so much chance of
sunshine and so on that branches off the
real weather doesn't branch at all
it's either rain or sunshine but nothing
in between or something between that but
not you're from Holland to be in between
you